the thin pale humanoid anomaly had just
found itself in Minecraft of all places
the all too familiar whale of emergency
alarms rang out through the corridors of
the foundation facility it had happened
again another containment breach of
course the on-site Personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a
situation like this so well versed in
what to do during an emergency that it
had become second nature whether they
were research staff evacuating for their
own safety or security teams moving in
to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose
anomaly was none other than
scp-096 all Foundation Personnel were
alerted and reminded not to look
directly at the creature there was just
one problem they couldn't look even if
they'd ignored their order to try nobody
could because the shy guy was nowhere to
be found well nowhere in the real world
at least
this whole situation bizarre even by
Foundation standards had all started
with an experiment involving a member of
the Disposable d-class Personnel yet
another dangerous convict serving one of
several life sentences now being used as
an Expendable human lab rat for the
foundation's often Sinister purposes the
experiment in question was an attempt to
further test the limitation of scp-096's
abilities by now the foundation had done
extensive research into the creature
known as the shy guy they knew its
particular brand of anomalous qualities
were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it being observed would
instantaneously send scp-096 into an
uncontrollable rage State causing it to
pursue its Observer until they were no
longer standing
scp-096 was known to be able to travel
at speeds so relentless it was pretty
much impossible to stop one moment it
was sobbing and screeching in itself
having just been observed and minutes
later the wide jawed long-limbed monster
was standing behind whoever had seen it
making its screaming face the image its
victim took to the Grave with them
Foundation researchers knew that
scp-096's rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that Speck it also
didn't matter how far away the Observer
was
scp-096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation was an
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
Personnel actually the first test
subject turned out more scrambled or
fried certainly overdone given the
amount of smoke coming from their ears
but eventually the research team had
perfected the device they dubbed the
neural harness a headset that could
translate a person's mind into pure
digital code their Consciousness would
be extracted from their body leaving
their physical form an empty shell while
a digital copy of them was able to
Traverse the local on-site computer
network of course the foundation wasn't
about to let a digitized d-class run
amok with their systems so their coding
experts wrote a number of specialized
parameters into their successful test
subject now the digital d-class could be
programmed to follow the foundation's
directive from his perspective it was
like he was floating through cyberspace
towards the system that the foundation
had directed him to a surveillance
camera inside
scp-096's cell that usually remained
inactive but not today the camera
blinked to life as soon as the d-class
is code-based consciousness reached it
and through it he was able to observe as
cp096 sitting against the far wall of
its containment chamber gently
whimpering and walking back and forth
that is until the creature felt that
same familiar sensation of being watched
it stood up enraged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later
scp-096 appeared to Blink out of
existence it hadn't worked the
experiment had failed and the digital
d-class began to panic before the
foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count technically his
digital self was separate from his
physical form so he might get out of
scp-096's clutches on a technicality but
it was impossible his body was already
burned out by the neural harness there
was no way for the d-class to transfer
himself back the was only one option
left hide and as it turned out someone
had forgotten to uninstall a certain
building game from a computer in one of
the foundation doctor's offices the
d-classes digitized mind zapped him into
Minecraft from his point of view it was
like he existed within the game itself
he did a computerized equivalent of
breathing a sigh of relief only to take
back all those ones and zeros in a
horrified gasp as he noticed a tall wiry
framed figure before him it hadn't
worked
scp-096 had still managed to follow him
into Minecraft even in a world of
computer code the shy guy was able to
dispatch its digital Observer quite
easily in what had once been a living
human mind in the form of binary code
was quickly deleted but that's when
scp-096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a
cube-shaped sun revealed a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated
scp-096 instilling a kind of childlike
Wonder in the shy guy the likes of which
it hadn't experience since well since it
couldn't remember when rather than
leaving instantly reappearing in its
containment chamber
scp-096 made the conscious decision to
start exploring there was a mountainous
biome surrounding scp-096 Stoney spiers
reaching up towards a clear sky with a
waterfall cascading its way down the
nearest of them at the foot of the
mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shy guy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surroundings it was used to was a little
harsh on scp-096's sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back at the
foundation traversing through long
winding corridors of stone as cp096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy guy's height in mind there
was a low Warm Glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer
despite the stone walls around it
feeling like a tighter confinement than
its cell approaching the source of the
light
scp-096 was relieved that the cave
opened out into a more spacious area the
grand tunnel giving way to an expansive
chamber that lay within the heart of the
mountain the warm orangey glow that had
been coming from a flowing stream of
boiling hot lava that seemed to trickle
down from somewhere above creating a
deadly fiery pool directly in the Shy
Guy's path but just before it could turn
back and leave the cave through the way
he came
scp-096 sensed that familiar feeling of
something observing him across the lava
pool on the other side was a creature
comprised of a green Cube for a head
with a long armless cuboid body and four
cubed feet if it had been present in the
real world it might have been made out
of leaves like a living shrub it was
staring directly at the shy guy from
across the lava only for this strange
newcomer to disappear a moment later the
creeper hissed before it realized that
scp-096 had leaped up behind it to land
a fatal blow but little did the
infamously anxious anomaly realized that
the sentient shrub wasn't done there was
a colossal boom that caused scp-096 to
stagger backwards whimpering at the
sudden loud explosion and the pain that
had accompanied it the creeper had blown
itself to Pieces but in doing so had
left a lasting injury that caused
scp-096 considerable discomfort as it
began limping towards the cave that led
out the opposite side of the mountain
despite its injury the shy guy was still
able to move with relative ease and the
further it went the more it seem to
gradually heal however it was as it
stepped out once more into the sunlight
that the creature realized just how
hungry it was back in the real world it
hadn't eaten for several hours and
surprisingly even while accidentally
stuck in digitized form the hunger
mechanics of Minecraft were having an
effect on
scp-096 the shy guy started searching
around for anything that could prove to
satiate its hunger there was a Grove of
trees not far so scp-096 lumbered to
take a closer look it couldn't be
certain but it felt there was at least a
slim chance that there were apples
growing amongst the leaves but even at
the anomaly's own elongated height it
couldn't simply reach up to pick them
however it was while swiping its arms up
at the tree that the shy guy swung its
Fist and knocked at the tree trunk to
the creature's surprise it was able to
chip away at the wood with its hands
punching at the tree until the trunk had
been reduced to a collection of wooden
blocks the shy guy was able to collect
and sure enough
some red apples dropped from the leaves
above enough to quell the hunger that
scp-096 was feeling at least for the
time being nearby something was moving
through the trees it was yet to lock
eyes on scp-096 but the second it did
the mob would surely have sealed its own
fate as it moved around minding its own
business the tall figure overheard the
sounds of the shy guy eating and its
attention was drawn to where the
creature was standing enjoying an apple
sensing that it had been seen as cp096
turned and locked eyes with the entity
it was perhaps the only other being in
Minecraft that was a similar height and
stature to the anomaly itself in fact
the pair were strikingly similar before
scp-096 could carry out its usual method
of attack the Enderman suddenly
teleported out of view but it was too
late now both it and the shy guy had
looked at the other's face both had been
provoked and were compelled to react in
exactly the same way just as scp-096
entered rage State the Enderman 2 opened
its mouth and began to shake making loud
lengthy sounds not dissimilar to the Shy
Guy's own angered screams but something
profoundly strange happened next
scp-096 and the Enderman kept attempting
to pursue one another appearing in a new
location within the Minecraft world
neither one getting close enough to the
other they'd teleport only for the other
to teleport away the moment they saw
each other each trying to catch one
another but always staying one step
behind this rapid Chase almost became a
strange ongoing sort of teleporting
dance between
scp-096 and the Enderman at first the
shy guy had been compelled to attack the
Enderman like it was with any who looked
directly at it but as they appeared and
disappeared from place to place the
creature started to feel an odd kinship
with this shadowy fellow it was so used
to being frightened and alone to its
overwhelming feelings of insecurity and
self-loathing that the Simplicity of
just traversing the open world for the
creature very alike itself in many ways
it at all come as a welcome change
scp-096 found it therapeutic even and
before long was following the Enderman
not out of any intention to do it harm
but just to feel for a little while like
it had a friend just a little bit longer
as cp096 thought welcoming the enjoyment
it felt playing this game of Minecraft
now go check out
scp-1471 Mal o but hacked Minecraft and
SCP Minecraft world Destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in The Crucible for more